Speaker 1: We have a voicemail number. That number
is 219 to David P. Now, yesterday during the show,
my microphone fell. It fell on me and it actually
smacked me in the face. And if you were listening
to yesterday's show, you might have heard me say,
oh, I just lost my microphone and heard a gong,
for lack of a better term. The video of the
microphone falling on me is on my Instagram,
which you can find it David Pakman.
This listener, this viewer, rather
called in about how close of a call I had
with the microphone yesterday. Listen to this.
Speaker 7: Hi, David. You need to go back and
rewatch your show when your microphone fell.
Because if you had not looked over to, I guess
it would have been your left that I think that
thing would have gotten you right in the eye. Oh,
my gosh. I think you're very lucky that you had.
It is the start of your faith and not your eye.
Oh, my gosh. I'm glad I did not get you in the
eye. Okay, well, I am one of your avid fans and
a member, so I appreciate your show. I enjoy
listening to it every day and have a nice day.
Speaker 1: Well, thank you for that. Yeah, no,
I did go back and I watched it slowly, sort of
like the Zapruder film frame by frame. And I did
take a little bit of a hit on the right side of
my face from the microphone falling. Had I been
looking in a different direction as the mic fell,
it could have gotten me in the eye. And I am not
a medical doctor, to be very clear, but I think
that that would have been bad. I think it might
have. I don't know that I would be here hosting
necessarily today had that taken place. So if
you're curious what that looked like, there is
video of it on my Instagram, which you can find
at David Pakman. We have a great bonus show for
you today. We're down to the final primaries of
2022. We'll tell you what they are and what to
watch and how things are looking. Number two,
Alabama is jailing pregnant cannabis users
to protect, quote, protect the fetuses.
What? Yes. And major credit card companies
are making it easier to track gun sales and
the gun people are furious. All of those
stories and more on today's bonus show.
Speaker 2: Oh, the bonus show where you
want to make money and everybody else
who makes money to fund themselves is back.
Speaker 1: Well, we do fund ourselves. Yes,
there is money exchanged with the bonus show.
You can sign up at join pacman dot com. You
will get instant access to the bonus show
and I look forward to seeing you back.